Today, as minister of families and on behalf of the people of Manitoba,
let me express our deepest sorrow and regret to every Manitoba child.
Denied the children's special allowance.
For 14 years, Manitoba required child and family services
agencies to return over $335 million in federal CSA payments,
funds meant to support your well being,
education and opportunities to thrive.
This was not just a financial mistake.
It was a profound injustice,
leaving some of our most vulnerable children
without the supports they needed
and rightfully deserved. These funds should have nourished your dreams,
helped you learn, grow and flourish.
We recognize the pain,
loss and harm caused by past government practices,
taking away that which was rightfully yours.
We are sorry.
Our government has taken a long overdue step in correcting this wrong.
We have agreed to a settlement of $530 million
to compensate those who were denied these funds.
This settlement is not just about writing the past.
It's about paving the way forward.
It's about restoring dignity,
healing wounds
and building a better future for the children of Manitoba.
To the children, young adults and families affected,
I say this, your courage,
your resilience,
your determination to stand up and demand fairness has been heard.
You are not just survivors.
You are warriors of justice.
You have been at the forefront of showing Manitobans
the path to reconciliation.
Meguitch, for your unwavering strength,
I stand before you not only as the minister responsible,
but also as someone who Feels this profoundly on a personal level.
I, like the minister of housing,
addictions and homelessness,
were once in children in care, too.
We understand deeply
what it means to experience the child welfare system.
And so today, we acknowledge the deep scars left by this deprivation,
scars carried not just by you,
but by families, friends and our communities.
Today is only the beginning of this journey.
Our government commits to continuing to learn from the past,
to listen and to act with integrity,
ensuring every child now and in the future
will grow up with the full support and love they deserve.
I also want to share something deeply personal.
I know healing is possible.
I know despite the hurt, unfairness and despite the obstacles,
there is a path of healing and a way forward.
You have the right to thrive,
to pursue education, to build careers,
to dream freely, and to live a life full of joy and opportunity.
Our greatest hope is you now have the space to not just survive,
but to truly thrive. We see you.
We see your beauty. We see your strength.
We believe in your future.
We believe in you. We are here to support your dreams
and want nothing more than for you to live a full,
joyful life that you so rightfully deserve.
You are loved today and always.